un monde meilleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plume et tendre
à menton
ce type d'action parce qu'on est obligés
de diversifier nos modes d'action on
n'est toujours pas entendu on à
l'opinion l'opinion est contre ce projet
e
le président de la république n'écoute
pas n'écoute pas l'opinion depuis le 5
décembre depuis déjà des journées dame
qui s'accumulent 40 jours de grève on
n'est toujours pas entendu n'écoute pas
la population on est obligé de diversité
diversifier nos modes d'action on n'a
pas le choix on ne peut pas laisser
passer ce projet plutôt contente en fait
qu'il fasse agréable mais soutient tu
pour une culture accessible à tous qui
est pas le cas en ce moment je sais
qu'ils se battent aussi pour ça pour
leur retraite c'est important il se bat
pour l'accès au louvre à tout le monde
dont sa gestion a fourré mais c'est pas
grave le nom devant si vous ne va pas
très loin et moi je viens de loin j'ai
eu du mal à prendre en trajet du mal à
défendre au fouillis si je peux pas voir
où je verse aux tirs ou pas et je peux
vous dire que tous les gens qu'on a vu
ce matin là y'a mieux reste plus grand
monde mais les gens sont contre les gens
ne sont pas contents sauf qu'on ne dit
rien et c'est bien dommage
on est content il ne devrait pas être là
faire une heure de piquets de grève
grève ok pour manifester leur avis très
bien emmerdé excusez moi le mot toute la
journée les gens qui viennent visiter
qui viennent de loin ça c'est honteux
[Musique]
pis